Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
(Violon)
(Applaudissements)
Je suis musicienne.
Pourtant, à deux reprises,
j'ai essayé d'arrêter le violon.
A 15 ans, je faisais un peu de la musique
parce que mes parents l'avaient décidé.
Je me suis arrêtée 3 mois.
Trois mois pour comprendre
que je voulais vraiment poursuivre
que c'était ma vocation,
que c'était une nécessité.
A 30 ans, j'avais un enfant,
j'étais mariée,
et j'avais beaucoup de mal à faire face
au stress et au rythme de vie.
J'ai arrêté les concerts plus d'un an.
Au début, ça a été un soulagement.
Et puis j'ai ressenti un manque,
très vite, j'ai eu l'impression
que je ne pouvais plus respirer,
que j'étouffais, comme si j'avais
un sac plastique sur la tête.
Encore aujourd'hui, il m'arrive
de rêver à une vie normale.
mais je sais que c'est pas possible.
La musique accompagne
tous mes moments de vie,
de doute, de joie,
de tristesse, de bonheur.
C'est comme une bulle,
qui me permet de voyager
qui me permet de sortir du quotidien,
et qui me relie à quelque chose
de beaucoup plus grand.
La musique donne sens à ma vie.
Elle donne sens à LA vie.
Ma pratique instrumentale,
je ma mets au service d'un compositeur.
J'approche chaque œuvre
avec tout ce que je sais
mais surtout tout ce que je suis.
Et petit à petit, l’œuvre se révèle.
C'est comme si j'établis un lien
entre un compositeur
qui est mort depuis très longtemps
la plupart du temps,
son œuvre,
et le public qui l'écoute aujourd'hui.
Je suis un peu passeur de musique.
Ce lien nous lie
dans l'espace et dans le temps,
et en cela nous fait toucher
quelque chose d'essentiel.
Cette pratique instrumentale
ne peut se faire que si je suis
pleinement ancrée en moi
dans l'instant présent,
libre de ce que je suis,
pour pouvoir me tourner vers l’œuvre,
la comprendre, et la partager.
Cette façon d'être
est essentielle en musique,
mais elle peut devenir
une philosophie de vie.
C'est un peu ma philosophie de vie.
Ancrée dans le présent,
dans l'instant présent,
libre de ce que je suis,
pour me tourner au mieux vers l'autre
et tenter de comprendre un peu le monde.
Cet accès au monde,
j'ai envie de le partager.
Je trouve que c'est un peu
ma légitimité à moi, musicienne,
à nous, musiciens.
Mais cette musique dite classique,
est-ce qu'elle est accessible à tous,
à tout moment, n'importe où ?
Un test a été fait aux États-Unis.
Joshua Bell,
qui est un très grand violoniste,
qui joue un des plus beaux instruments
au monde, un Stradivarius,
a accepté de jouer à 9 heures du matin
dans le métro de Washington.
La vidéo, que vous avez peut-être vue,
est impressionnante.
Les gens continuent à courir,
personne ne lève les yeux.
La veille, il jouait
devant mille personnes.
Certaines personnes avaient payé
jusqu'à 100 dollars leur place.
Le lendemain, la même personne
dans le métro a récolté 34 dollars.
(Rires)
En 45 minutes.
Dont vingt par la seule personne
qui l'a reconnu.
(Rires)
Ce que cela nous dit,
c'est quand nous sommes dans cette course,
dans cette agitation intérieure
que l'on connaît tous,
nous ne sommes pas disponibles.
Nous ne pouvons percevoir la beauté,
nous arrêter pour l'apprécier
et reconnaître le talent.
La musique,
parce qu'elle se déroule dans le temps,
nécessite de s'apaiser,
de se mettre en éveil.
Au concert, petit à petit,
le silence se fait.
Le vrai silence.
Le silence qui rend disponible.
Celui que nous vivons actuellement
et qui nous relie.
Ce sont des moments de communion palpable.
La différence, c'est que je vous parle.
Je fais passer, j'essaye, un message.
Eh bien, ce qui est merveilleux en
musique, c'est qu'il n'y a pas UN message.
Chacun peut partir dans son univers,
faire son voyage,
se raconter son histoire.
Alors, ces moments de partage,
j'ai toujours envie de les vivre
avec un plus grand nombre
parce que je ne pense pas
que la musique soit élitiste.
Je pense qu'elle est accessible à tous.
Il suffit de s'apaiser,
de se rendre disponible,
de se faire ce silence intérieur
qui rend disponible à la beauté,
à la musique,
mais c'est le même silence qui rend
disponible à la connaissance,
à l'amitié, à l'amour, à la vie.
Ramzi Abu Radwan est un jeune Palestinien.
A 7 ans, il participe
à la première intifada
et il voit mourir
une grande partie de sa famille.
Loin d'avoir peur, il nourrit
une soif de vengeance.
A 17 ans, il rencontre
un musicien jordanien,
qui lui propose d'apprendre l'alto.
L'alto, c'est un peu comme le violon,
c'est pas très facile.
Et pourtant, il accepte,
mais il est persuadé
qu'il arrêtera au bout d'un mois
parce que cette pratique est élitiste
et surtout, elle est tellement loin
de ses préoccupations quotidiennes.
Pourtant, à l'issue des master classes,
il désire poursuivre.
Il a découvert le moyen de fuir
l'occupation, les camps de réfugiés.
La musique lui permet de passer
les barrières, les frontières, les murs.
Il décide de poursuivre sa formation
en France et aux États-Unis.
Sept ans après, il revient à Ramala.
Et là, il a un choc.
En France, les murs des écoles
sont tapissés de dessins
de princesses, de princes charmants,
de maisons, de fleurs, d'arbres.
Eh bien à Ramala, les murs sont tapissés
de chars, de mitrailleuses, de kamikazes.
Et Ramzi réalise à quel point la musique
a transformé sa façon de voir le monde.
Alors, il va jouer dans les écoles.
Et là, encore une fois,
la vidéo est impressionnante.
parce que très vite,
les murs sont tapissés
de notes de musique
et d'instruments de musique.
Et il réalise à quel point il est possible
de modeler l'esprit d'un enfant,
d'un être humain,
de changer sa conscience.
Aujourd'hui, Ramzi Abou Redvan nous dit :
« Des pierres au violon,
c'est le même combat que je mène.
On peut détruire une maison,
ériger un mur.
On ne peut pas vous voler
votre âme, votre identité. »
Il dit aussi : « Le monde du son
est capable de hisser l'individu
de l'inquiétude pour sa propre existence
à une perception universelle
de sa place parmi les êtres humains. »
J'ai toujours eu envie,
et je suis toujours allée jouer
dans des lieux qui ne sont pas consacrés
à la musique classique.
Alors dans le milieu, on appelle ça
« aller vers les nouveaux publics ».
Moi, je vais vers LE public.
En 2001, j'ai initié, avec des amis,
une série de musique de chambre,
à Trappes-en-Yvelines.
C'est une banlieue difficile,
dite difficile, de la banlieue parisienne.
Soyons très honnête :
pendant plusieurs années,
nous avons touché
entre 20 et 50 personnes au concert,
essentiellement composé de nos amis,
je les remercie,
(Rires)
et de quelques mélomanes.
Heureusement, dès le début,
il y a eu ces moments avec les enfants.
Cette jeune fille noire,
à l'issue d'un concert,
qui nous demande de lui parler du piano,
des touches blanches, des touches noires…
Alors on essaie de lui expliquer,
les demi-tons, la gamme, on lui joue…
Rien n'y fait.
Alors, d'elle-même, elle vient sur scène,
elle effleure une touche blanche,
elle écoute une touche noire,
et nous dit :
« Vous voulez dire
qu'il n'y a aucune différence. »
Ou cet enfant de deux ans,
lors d'un concert
pour des jeunes filles-mères.
Cet enfant de deux ans qui signifie
clairement à sa maman
qui veut quitter en plein milieu
de l’œuvre le concert,
que lui veut rester.
Eh bien l'enfant est resté,
sur les genoux d'une autre maman.
Mais ce qui est beau,
c'est que trois jours plus tard,
il y avait un concert « officiel »,
et dans la salle,
il y avait la jeune maman au premier rang.
Elle est juste venue me voir
avec ses amies
et me dire qu'elle s'était éclatée.
Et puis il y a ces moments,
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines,
des concerts « Enfants en scène »,
qui réunissent un orchestre professionnel
et un chœur qui travaille toute l'année,
qui regroupe des enfants
des quartiers de Trappes-en-Yvelines.
Quand j'ai fait ce concert,
et que j'ai vu le lever de rideau,
entendre tous ces enfants chanter ensemble
le chœur de Carmen,
alors que quelques instants avant,
on vérifiait qu'ils n'avaient rien
de dangereux dans les poches.
C'était quelque chose de fort.
Pourtant, je vais être très franche :
quand j'ai traversé Trappes,
à pied, un samedi après-midi, pour aller
de la gare à la salle de concert,
je me suis dit que ce que je faisais
n'avait aucun sens.
C'était certainement le fruit
d'une pensée généreuse.
Mais c'était aussi le fruit
d'une pensée prétentieuse
de quelqu'un de très privilégié.
Comment pouvais-je prétendre, moi,
apporter la musique, soit disant vitale,
à des gens qui, eux,
avaient de réelles passions vitales,
se loger et manger.
Heureusement, ce soir-là, au premier rang,
il y avait une jeune femme noire
et ses trois enfants,
qui est venue me voir à la fin du concert,
qui m'a simplement remerciée en me disant
que ces moments faisaient
désormais partie de sa vie.
Ou cette femme, seule,
qui me dit attendre le prochain concert
et qui me dit, qui m'écrit :
« C'est de ce souffle
dont j'ai besoin pour respirer. »
Ce sont des mots
qui me parlent, qui me touchent.
Aujourd'hui, la salle est comble.
Plus de dix ans.
Tout récemment, nous avons joué devant…
nous avons donné des concerts scolaires
devant des enfants, 1500 enfants entre 7
et 10 ans, des quartiers de Trappes.
Au programme, c'était le Tzigane de Ravel.
Alors le Tzigane de Ravel,
c'est pas vraiment
une œuvre très accessible a priori.
En général, dans ce genre de concert,
on présente plutôt Pierre et le Loup,
Le Carnaval des Animaux
ou les Quatre Saisons de Vivaldi.
Donc, c'est un peu un défi.
On essaye donc de présenter l'orchestre,
expliquer les sources d'inspiration,
et puis, on a prévu
de jouer tout le Tzigane.
Il faut savoir que le Tzigane commence
par une cadence pour violon seul
de cinq minutes.
Alors vous pouvez imaginez ce que c'est
pour un enfant de 7 ans
qui n'a jamais entendu de musique,
d'écouter un violon seul
pendant 5 minutes.
Le chef d'orchestre n'y croit pas du tout,
il me dit : « Marianne, je te conseille
de couper la cadence. »
Bon, ça m'ennuie un peu, je me dis,
je vais essayer au moins
à la première séance.
Je me donne quelques chances,
je donne des clés d'écoute,
comme des petites balises dans une balade.
« Alors vous allez rencontrer l'alouette,
et il va se passer telle chose,
et le violon va monter là-haut… »,
et je me lance.
Je pense ne jamais avoir
entendu un tel silence.
Le silence intérieur de 500 enfants.
Et le plus beau silence
que j'aie jamais vécu.
C'est un cadeau qu'ils m'ont fait,
que nous avons partagé.
Ce sont ces moments qui donnent
un vrai sens à ma vie d'artiste.
Le lendemain, au concert officiel,
nous avons eu de nombreuses
réservations, nouvelles.
Parce que les enfants qui étaient venus
la veille avaient réussi à convaincre
leur maman, leur frère, leur sœur,
de pousser la porte du concert officiel,
et de venir écouter.
Dans la salle, de nombreuses femmes
étaient voilées.
Dans ces moments, ce sont
ces moments qui comptent pour moi.
Je me sens passeur de quelque chose
de plus permanent que la vie,
passeur de lumière, je l'espère.
La musique m'est vitale,
c'est comme une bulle
qui me permet de voyager.
Ensemble.
La vie sans musique
est tout simplement une erreur.
(Applaudissements)
(Violon)